What is it? It looks like Princess Chitomi can dance with
Shion. [Music] To be honest, I don't really want to dance with Shion,
but since it's a great opportunity, I'll make you fall
gracefully. I hope you're at least embarrassed in front of everyone.
I see.  I thought something was wrong with me, so I
followed her. When I saw that Bao-san was in trouble, I left her alone, and His
Highness Shion would get mad at me. Should I help her? Is it true? But what
should I do? It's
such a simple thing.
[Music] I
thought she was a graceful princess, but she's surprisingly old.
[Music] Her
dancing skills are higher than I expected. It's just that
Prince Shion is good at dancing.
Only one person can dance well.
You all know that I'm just spinning around in vain.
Rafina
[Music] The
splendid dance that captivates the onlookers is only
possible because of the high level of skill on both sides
[Music]
T